wolltet ihr vor 25 jahren eine der
handvoll websites die es damals gab
aufrufen da das in etwa so
aus seitdem hat sich das world wide web
rasant entwickelt und wurde vom netzwerk
um noch winzige daten auszutauschen zu
einer art zweitem zu hause für viele von
uns in dem es inzwischen nicht mehr nur
in der hand voll sondern milliarden von
zeichen gibt es egal ob homepages blogs
social media streaming dienste oder
shops von unternehmen wirklich jeder und
seine großmutter haben die website aber
ich als jemand einen ganzen tag im
internet rumhängt als irgendwie noch
nicht aber wie geht das überhaupt im
laufe der zeit ist das netz für uns
konsumenten ja auch deutlich
zugänglicher geworden und jeder art von
diensten wie wordpress square space oder
mix gehört mit denen man angeblich
selbst komplett ohne können der website
machen kann ohne auch nur eine zeile
code vor mir also wenn ich schon ob das
wirklich so wie sie ist und auf meine
website hinterher wirklich mit denen von
großen firmen zeigen kann dir dafür
ganze teams von profis haben dieses
video wird unterstützt von hosting
kleiner fun fact früher hatten einige
seiten auch noch richtige öffnungszeiten
und hatten sonntags einfach geschlossen
bei einigen religiösen seiten ist das
zwar heute auch noch der fall aber davon
abgesehen ist der witz eines
internetauftritts ja gerade dass er 24 7
erreichbar ist die allererste website
ist sogar heute noch erreichbar und auf
ihr findet man einfach so ein paar infos
darüber was das world wide web überhaupt
ist
in
die technik entwickelt sich und mit
javascript css flash und besseren
internet leitungen werden web entwickler
immer mächtiger und diese macht wurde
auch erst einmal ausgereizt
so sei also die zukunft von damals aus
inzwischen geht der trend aber wieder
deutlich zu schlichteren und
übersichtlichen seiten bei denen allem
nicht sofort die augen wehtun und in die
richtung wird es mir auch gehen der
grund warum ich eine webseite will ist
dass ich auf youtube echt viele projekte
ins leben rufen die auch unabhängig von
youtube weiter existieren und ganz
eigene communitys entwickeln und ich
will dass man sich auf toggo.de mit
einem blick eine komplette übersicht
darüber machen kann dieses projekt haben
ihre eigenen social media profile disco
server mit über 5.000 mitgliedern app
store einträge und auch eigene websites
die ich übrigens nicht selbst gemacht
habt also daraus geld punkt kommt für
meine app das noch unfertige merkel
punkt kommt für den mac ribéry rpg für
unsere minecraft server tom murry punkt
learn world.com für einen schnittkurs
und tommy punkt shop für unsere leute
und ich glaube da kann es gar nicht
schaden da man über sich lachen zu
bringen zum beispiel für leute die neu
dazu gekommen sind und dass eben nicht
alles mitgekriegt haben vom prinzip her
wird also ähnlich wie link green nur
deutlich cooler ich erstelle also zuerst
eine übersicht mit einem größeren
projekten die ich ins leben gerufen habe
als großen kreis anschließend drei ich
drum herum alle zu dem jeweiligen
projekt zugehörigen website links und
social media profile auf in form von
kleineren kreisen und mit diesen gruppen
aufbau setze ich mich jetzt an das
programm mit dem ich die website bauen
will willkommen bei wordpress ja cool hh
hallo wo bin ich hier den text anderen
farbe ja gut im beet angezogen mit
hochladen ja ein nächstes und fertig
oder kann man kann man einen zu machen
wenn man alles und jeder blanke
geschichten haben hier kann man sagen
dass ihr comeback als nächstes will ich
um die haupt button sie wurden die
kleinen buttons anordnen wie in meiner
skizze und das ist gar nicht mal so
leicht weil eigentlich alles immer in
boxen angeordnet wird die suche wirklich
lange wie ich das in wordpress einfach
so umsetzen kann bis ich mich dann auf
die suche nach plugins mache die einem
einzelne sachen deutlich leichter machen
können da ich da nichts brauchbares
finden und auch gar keinen plan mehr von
sinus und cosinus und winkel
berechnungen sonstwas hat wir rechnen
nicht mit einem anderen programm welche
genaue xy position die ereignis haben
müssen um im perfekten kreis angeordnet
zu sein und übertrage diese position
daneben auf meine icons und damit alles
hübsch aussieht bleiben die buttons
natürlich nicht einfach grausam eine
übersicht ich suche mir also einige
icons und passende bilder zu den
projekten heraus und verwandelt sie in
photoshop zu gründen icons die ich dann
in die website einbau bevor ich
anschließend jeden einzelnen der buttons
mit dem richtigen link verknüpfen das
wirklich besondere was ich mit der
website vorhaben fehlt zwar noch aber
dazu kommen wir gleich das grundgerüst
steht jetzt und sieht schon mal echt
nice aus aber bevor ich mich jetzt an
den feinschliff nach fahre ich erst mal
ein paar leute wie die zu finden damit
aber überhaupt der auf die website
gelangen kann muss die seite erst mal
auf einem server mittels web hosting
gehostet werden und das geht zum
beispiel mit hausding dem sponsor des
heutigen video ich habe mir einfach das
premium web hosting aus gewesen im
nächsten schritt könnten dann die
laufzeit auswählen und hier den coach
tommy eingeben für einen extra rabatt so
dass er für ein jahren auf 34 eur 39
zahlt dann einfach diese drei fragen
beantworten und eure webseite finden
oder wie ich mit wordpress und erstellen
basierend auf euren antworten werden
templates vorgeschlagen falls es euch
ein bisschen leichter machen wollt also
ich zusätzlich gibt es bei hausding auch
noch eine eigene domain kostenlos dazu
die ihr hier auswählen könnt nachdem die
website bereits zum veröffentlichen ich
klicke ich einfach hier im expanded auf
veröffentlichen und zack kann alle welt
24/7 darauf zugreifen 24 7 mussten
übrigens auch die kundenbetreuung bei
hosting mehr zur verfügung weil sie mal
fragen habt klickt auf den link in der
video beschreibung wenn ihr ganz easy
für wenig geld und in wenigen schritten
auch eine eigene website erstellen volt
und nutzt den connery für extra rabatt
auf alle hosting pakete und falls ihr
euch doch anders entscheiden sollte gibt
es eine 30 tage geld zurück garantie
amazon.de 1 das thema ist noch nicht
fertig da fehlen auch der feinschliff
aber bevor wir dann feinstes man wollte
ich das mal und zwar der meinung da
würde ich hier nicht sagen sonst das
habe ich auch gern gesehen denn das ist
je nachdem wo man je nachdem wie das
skalieren ist sieht das anders aus das
heißt da muss man drauf daran denken
dass man ja alles response if design
muss aber das stimmt gerade bei den
damen scripting oder hier und auch
rechts
also ich muss sagen es ist sehr viel
info mache ich gern meinen wirklichen
job also voll in meinem element ich
finde die idee megageil das haben wir so
ein bisschen was anderes einfach das
finde ich schon sehr cool und aber
zurück zu kommen das ist sehr belastend
ist nicht hat das so geplant dass man
eigentlich als nur die icons sieht also
diese haupt länger darauf wenn man drauf
geht dass sie dann ja okay dann okay
wenn ich mir das so vorstellen dann
finde ich geil ich fand's einfach uncool
wenn du dann mit der maus auf gießen ist
ein bisschen responsive sind und das
ging auch so bleibt und einfach ja ich
weiss es macht sinn dass der hintergrund
ein bisschen simpel ist dadurch wirkt
das so unfertig dadurch dass im
hintergrund nichts wenn du jetzt bei der
im dunklen bleiben möchte ist das dann
quasi hier wieso das um das ding immer
probleme heller wird oder so was ich
weiß ich halt irgendwas sind diese diese
einzelnen punkte hervorheben ich muss
mir natürlich auch gerade versucht sich
vorstellen dass die dinger nicht da sind
dann weiß ich natürlich dann auch cool
fände wenn man darauf kommen dass wir so
wenige sachen sind dass das direkt an
hier im zentrum ist und nicht zu essen
und trinken runter scrollen muss und
quasi alles zu in der mitte leben
gekommen ich habe da unten noch so
button für mein team zu machen und
arbeiten für sonstige sachen es gibt
noch ein paar andere projekte die halt
nicht so riesig sein dass in einem
button für das brettspiel das
gärtnerhaus kammerspielen dann was ich
noch ganz gut fände das wenn das alles
mehr oder weniger gleich sortiert ist
welche hast du den ortschronisten
ursprung hier und du hast du nur sprung
dar die idee ganz cool schon dass der
ursprung hat direkt das oberster ist das
stimmt ich finde es komisch dass das
hier groß geschrieben sind alles andere
denn die kleinen er sagt also ich finde
eine allgemeine idee hat richtig cool
war das halt schon eher ungewöhnlich ist
gut dann seid ihr gesagt getan wird das
feedback also umgesetzt was sich vor
allem auf die texte bezieht außerdem
füge ich noch einen button für mein team
hinzu wo ihr wenn ihr wollt auch deren
social media abchecken könnt falls euch
interessiert wäre ja alles mit arbeitet
außerdem kam noch ein button für
sonstige projekte hinzu wie zb mein
eigenes brettspiel oder den ticker kanal
unserem welcher 4 und ich ja mal das
sprechen beigebracht haben
[Musik]
du hast angst wovor hast du angst wir
glauben nicht dass die angst vor sophie
hat sondern dass ich einfach gesehen hat
war sie nicht verstanden was ich gerade
mache jetzt kommt das eigentliche
highlight die animationen die ich zum
teil sogar vom ausmache und wir hiermit
habe ich das mit dem auto dann auch zum
aller ersten mal veröffentlicht die wahl
des autos sollte wahrscheinlich kein
verbunden weil es wirklich ein lange
gehegter traum wahr freut euch auf jeden
fall schon mal auf das video in dem ich
versuche mit meinen menschengroßen
hamsterrad den tesla aufzuladen aber
zurück zur website das animieren ist
extrem kompliziert und außer wenn man
privat verwendet für mich kaum machbar
in wordpress weswegen ich das mit einem
extra plugin mache und selbst damit
dauert es einen ganzen tag bis ich das
hier geschafft habt einen button der
einfach nur keiner wird wenn man mit der
maus traum geht wenn ich jetzt drauf
gehen dann kommt auch der 1 button raus
hat schon mal sehr gut fehlen noch ganz
viele andere jetzt kommen alle buttons
draußen sind schon richtig geil aussehen
ich hab so eingestellt dass die einer
nach dem anderen kommt dass es nicht auf
einmal ist er mir als problem ist die
bleiben jetzt alle draußen und das sind
also unübersichtlich aus sie sollen sich
eigene zurückgehen jetzt ist das problem
dass die buttons kommen wenn ich auf
diesen button drauf gehen aber wenn ich
dann diesen großen button verlassen dann
verschwinden die kleinen wieder und dann
kann ich dir nicht anklicken oder also
was jetzt dass sie beruflich
ich glaube ich habe es gerade komplett
zerschossen ich weiß nicht was das sein
soll und
ich runter und es funktioniert er ist
achter rein raus bereits das
funktioniert es geht endlich mit allen
und das war ultra aufwendig ist es umso
schöner dass es jetzt geklappt manchmal
packt ihn noch ein bisschen rum aber
ansonsten sieht das doch sehr sehr gut
so jetzt habe ich es auch so eingestellt
dass sich diese kleinen ball ist auch
bewegen dass da irgendwie ein bisschen
mehr leben drin ist und ich natürlich
frischen und also ich finde es richtig
gut ich bin so richtig schön um echt zu
sein ich werde die website das ist ich
habe jetzt tatsächlich das ganze ding
auch mal aufs handy formatiert das war
tatsächlich gar nicht mal so schwierig
und ich kann jetzt einmal auf toggo.de
gehen hier übrigens natürlich auch in
der video verlinkt man kann man denn er
durchblicken und sieht man schon dass
alles funktioniert ihr könnt natürlich
auch gern mit ihr viel erfindet mithin
kommentar schreiben welche
verbesserungsvorschläge also ich
hinterrad des funktionalen handy auch
richtig gut alle links öffnen sich wenn
man darauf klickt und man kann so
schauen was ist ganz unten sieht man
nochmals team dann kann man ja mal
reinklicken und reinschauen die
sebastians instagram so aussehe oder das
von alle oder was yuan superstar sich am
handy auch toll finde ist da kann man ja
nicht aber mit dem ausgang darüber gehen
wenn man das öffnen sich die babbel
setzt wenn man darauf tippt habe ich so
angestellt und ja die bubbles zieht sich
erst dann zurück wenn man auf die
nächste drauf dass ich so eine kugel ist
an zeit gebraucht habe ich dafür jetzt
übrigens mit allem drum und dran und
kann und zwar um sofort fünf tage und
das für nur eine einzige seite wenn
jetzt auch noch bekommen auf einer
eigenen webseite dann schaut mal wieder
beschreibung bei hosting vorbei mit den
hessen überhaupt kein problem und wenn
euch das video gefallen hat und er gerne
mehr sehen würdet abonniert gerne das
sind wiederum leichter schreibt mir gern
was er von der website haltet und dann
im nächsten jahr gut
[Musik]